hi my name is Phil Rob and the
co-founder of Turtle Rock Studios and
today we are showing off some new stuff
for our game evolved
so today we're showing off for new
hunters we've already introduced for
hunters previously we've got four more
to introduce you to the first hunter is
hide is our new assault class his main
thing is that he has a flamethrower so
what that means for hide is that he is
in monster space constantly he also has
something called toxic grenades unlike
Markov who was able to set up traps for
the monster with his mind's eye is able
to flush the monster by throwing his
topspin aid into an area where a monster
might be hiding the second new character
is our medic character his name's
Lazarus he is the exact opposite of vow
Lazarus is basically he's a space
necromancer he can bring people back
from the dead he doesn't have a lot of
ability to sort of heel on the fly
during a battle but once his teammates
go down he can sneak in using his
personal cloak and revived somebody the
monster feels like he's making this
great progress and stomping stomping
stomping on under after hunted somehow
the hunters just keep coming back our
new trapper is named Maggie and Maggie
has a pet traviata named Daisy trap jaws
are sort of indigenous scavengers on the
planet shear which is where the game
takes place the thing that Daisy does
for the team is that she acts much like
a bloodhound she's got a very keen sense
of smell so she's able to track the
monster the other thing she has are she
has a harpoon mines now where Griffin
our previous trapper was very direct he
shoots the harpoon directly into the
monster Maggie can set up traps and sort
of kill zones so that when the monster
comes through the harpoon traps
automatically trigger and grab and you
know fuss setting him up for any other
number of combos and the last one he has
the most personality of all the hunters
which is odd because he's a robot his
name is bucket he's our support
character eventually you know his head
pops off and it flies around the world
looking for the monster and he's able to
sort of track the monster
the team so when the UAV gets the
monster in his sight if he keeps them in
sight long enough he'll actually
highlight for the rest of the team
another thing he can do is he pops up in
his belly and sentry guns come out he
can drop up the five of these in an area
and he's able to set up very effective
kill zones those are for new hunters
very different from the original for
hunters that we introduced and they
should add you know a whole new level of
variety to the game stay tuned for more
information and we look forward to
talking to you more about the ball